acho que meu coração nunca bateu tão
forte na vida assim é uma experiência
bastante única aqui é primeiro lugar eu
queria agradecer pela oportunidade de
poder compartilhar uma história nas
últimas três semanas eu refletir
bastante sobre a contribuição que eu
queria trazer aqui pra vocês e isso
deixa de dormir algumas noites por isso
e eu chamei a minha fala de um caminho
de consciência porque hoje eu acredito
que como tema do evento e consciência o
caminho de consciência ele só começa
quando a gente passa a se aceitar e mais
do que isso fazer algo positivo da nossa
própria identidade
eu nunca conseguia falar sobre isso
abertamente na minha vida é a primeira
vez que eu trago esse assunto
publicamente e precisa ter bastante
coragem para falar sobre assuntos como
esse mas o fato de ter sofrido violência
pela minha natureza ela sempre foi um
divisor de águas na minha vida pra mim
existiam dois jogos em chicago que ao
longo de seu desenvolvimento procurava
ser um profissional de destaque que
procurava ser respeitado pelas suas
acções e um tiago do foro íntimo que não
se aceitava se considera uma pessoa não
merecedora de felicidade
enquanto esses dois jogos não se
encontrasse eu jamais conseguiria
encontrar um caminho para ser feliz e eu
queria trazer aqui pra vocês uma imagem
que transmitisse um pouco da mensagem
que eu quero passar nesse momento eu
encontrei essa imagem na minha pré
adolescência eu tinha 12 anos e foi na
minha primeira comunhão
como eu sou de uma cidade pequena os
meus pais não são religiosos mas é um
ritual importante é servido ea minha mãe
decidiu então ao invés de alugar ou
comprar um traje social como a maioria
das famílias fazem ela comprou uma roupa
nova para que eu pudesse utilizar depois
na minha vida
só que tinha um problema eu tinha os
cabelos levemente cumpridos
eu tinha traços angelicais os detalhes
da roupa eles eram rosa
ao chegar na frente da igreja estava me
achando super bonito diferente mas a
professora da catequese ela pediu que
entrasse na igreja separado dos demais
enquanto os meninos entraram ao lado das
meninas por ordem de tamanho e odilon
gera mais altas da turma
eu entrei sozinho na igreja e ao entrar
na igreja os olhares foram de surpresa e
espanto e eu acho que até o julgamento
eu me assustei com aquilo eu não sabia
como lidar com aquela situação
levei uns três anos pra olhar de novo
essas fotos e eu rasguei todas as fotos
e por algum motivo essa foto acabou
salvando eu também demorou um bom tempo
para compreender o comprar um
comportamento da minha mãe
inicialmente achei que ela tinha exposto
demais mas na verdade hoje eu entendo
que aquele movimento dela era um
movimento de aceitação da minha
sexualidade que para ela apesar dos
olhares da sociedade
eu era uma criança linda e uma criança
normal
a seqüência da minha vida eu passei por
uma série de situações de bullying como
todos o com muitos homossexuais passam
eu sofri bullying na escola eu sofro
bullying na faculdade eu sofri bullying
no trabalho mas na verdade não é
exatamente sobre bullying que gostaria
de falar aqui porque eu acho que a gente
precisa aprender a fazer as coisas
negativas que acontecem na nossa vida
algo positivo para que a gente seja
serão seres humanos melhores mas é
evidente que situações de preconceito de
violência elas têm consequências no
nosso comportamento e até os meus 30
anos eu era uma pessoa antissocial
reprimida agressiva e eu não conseguia
me compreender e com isso eu também não
conseguia compreender o outro por eu ter
sofrido preconceito eu absorvi
preconceito dentro de mim e eu me tornei
uma pessoa preconceituosa
eu fui preconceituoso comigo eu fui
preconceituoso com outros homossexuais
eu era preconceituoso com as pessoas em
geral pra mim era meio que a lei da ação
e reação como recebe violência eu achava
que deveria devolver à violência para o
mundo que deveriam reprimir o
comportamento de todos os meus três
jeitos
a indy homossexual para que ele não
sofresse mais violência com isso mas é
evidente que esse modelo não se sustenta
eu me sentia também uma pessoa sozinha
no mundo como venho de uma cidade de 20
mil habitantes na minha época de
adolescente a internet ainda não era
popular
eu achava que eu era o único homossexual
do mundo e que por isso não era
merecedor de felicidade que eu realmente
era uma pessoa normal com o tempo e os
dados e das informações
com isso serão compartilhados na
internet eu tive acesso a informações
como essa
uma pesquisa da fipe com 500 escolas
brasileiras revelou que 26 por cento dos
alunos declara que não nos aceita que
25% dos alunos acredito que nós somos
nós não somos pessoas confiáveis que 23
por cento acredita que nós somos doentes
tudo isso eu já pensei sobre mim hoje
graças a deus eu não penso mas isso
também também desenvolveu uma certa
raiva pelo modelo escolar
eu tinha muita ira com as escolas em que
acontecia na sala de aula mas com o
tempo também ressignifica essa raiva
entende que na verdade as escolas nada
mais são do que reflexo da sociedade
enquanto a sociedade não mudar a escola
também não vai mudar
nesse sentido eu trago mais uma
informação importante
segundo dados do disque denúncia nos
últimos quatro anos o índice djia
denúncia em relação à homofobia aumentou
em 400 60% e essa informação ela tem
dois olhares um positivo que é nós
homossexuais estamos conseguindo falar
mais sobre isso e reivindicar nossos
direitos e outro que pode ser que
intolerância têm aumentado
independente da importância que a gente
faça desse dado o que eu acho que na
sociedade brasileira a gente precisa
ainda discutir muito tolerância e
aceitação do outro
eu pergunto pra vocês não só em relação
à aceitação aos homossexuais em relação
à aceitação do outro independente de
quem ele seja e quando você se olha no
espelho o que vocês vêem vocês aceitam o
cabelo de vocês no meu caso a falta dele
vocês aceitam o peso de vocês
o gênero de vocês e vocês aceitam um do
outro e até que ponto a gente contribui
para que esses preconceitos velados
continuem acontecendo na sociedade
será que não é hora da gente
ressignifica tudo isso e como a situação
da comunhão que o trouxe para você assim
que aquilo aconteceu comigo por ser
diferente olhar e julgamento eu ainda
acho que a sociedade hoje ela também
esquematizada privilegiar algumas
pessoas são os héteros são os brancos
são os ricos e como é que a gente sai
conscientemente desses modelos
a gente foi educado para aceitar certos
comportamentos e não questionar a roupa
que a gente usa os brinquedos que são de
unidos por gênero as tarefas domésticas
que são associadas a mulheres
o jeito de se portar quem foi que
definiu tudo isso será que não está na
hora da gente ressignifica e mudar essas
coisas eu aprendi a duras penas que
quanto mais o julgasse o outro
- eu seria compreendido e quando quando
comecei a oferecer compreensão do mundo
o mundo também começou a me compreender
isso virou um mantra na minha vida de
todos os dias eu tenho de falar isso
julgamento afasta compreensão aproxima
julgamento afasta compreensão aproxima e
com isso eu entendia que na verdade
seguir não deveria ser um assunto a ser
discutido na sociedade não deveria ser
relevante eu precisei de dois anos
terapia para compreender isso entender
que eu sou o thiago eu sou um ser humano
uma pessoa de bem com erros e acertos e
que eu mereço ser feliz assim como todos
vocês merecem
eu aprendi isso com uma das pessoas que
me trouxe mais aprendizado na vida essa
pessoa aqui hoje com seus 80 anos me
assistindo
obrigado foi na cozinha da minha avó
mas emília conceição da câmera que eu
aprendi a ser gente pra ela a minha
sexualidade nunca precisa ser pauta a
ser discutida ela nunca me fez essa
pergunta e não foi por medo da resposta
foi porque pra ela eu sempre foi o neto
dela o tiago um ser humano que merece
respeito cuidado afeto e aceitação como
todo ser humano não somente só eu
foi o amor da minha avó que eu acho que
me salvou do vício e da alta direção ea
partir desse gesto dela eu entendia que
a humanidade precisa não é da nossa
agressividade nem dos nossos medos mas
sempre que a gente conseguiu alcançar
isso o amor o amor próprio o amor pelo
outro eo amor inclusive pelas pessoas
que a gente não consegue compreender e
foi nesse momento que eu consegui me
libertar
eu consegui me libertar o meu emprego eu
consegui me libertar os meus
preconceitos mais densas que estavam
dentro de mim e quando eu consegui me
libertar dessa carga pesada que existe
dentro de mim e eu consegui fazer com
que o amor em tratos e foi daí que
surgiu o meu projeto empreendedor foi
dessa libertação que eu consegui
entender o meu talento e as coisas
positivas que eu poderia fazer na minha
vida foi na cozinha da minha vó eu me
descobri foi a partir da sensibilidade
dela que eu desenvolvi minha
sensibilidade
não precisei fazer cursos de gastronomia
e não precisa fazer nada eu simplesmente
precisa de você deixar sair de dentro
aquilo que já existia a partir da
relação que tive com ela e aí as coisas
começaram a ser leves na vida as coisas
começaram a sair de uma maneira muito
tranquila e muito bonita e hoje eu não
acho que eu tenho uma marca que eu tenho
uma empresa que pode virar uma empresa
internacional que com isso eu posso ser
milionário isso pra mim na verdade não
importa o que eu considero que eu tenho
um projeto de vida que eu compartilho
com os outros ea partir do momento em
que eu me aceitei me entende como ser
humano eu passei a desenvolver um
sentimento bastante importante
hoje no mundo que a empatia hoje consigo
compreender o sofrimento do outro eu
consigo consigo compreender o
desenvolvimento do outro ea importância
de a gente conseguir despertar o nosso
talento do outro eu procuro fazer isso
no meu projeto
as pessoas que trabalham comigo não são
funcionários elas são pessoas sonhadoras
que sonham sonhos dela junto comigo
ontem à noite ele gravar uma mensagem
pra mim porque durante a semana eles
perceberam que estava um pouco tenso de
estar aqui neste palco e porque eu não
escondo mais o meu jeito e eles mandaram
uma mensagem de positividade para mim
não tem nada mas bacana na vida do que
receber gestos de carinho e esse gesto
de carinho sou muito grato por hoje
consegui ter encontrado
e foi só a partir do respeito da
situação a minha o outro que entende que
o mundo pode ser mais leve
as coisas não precisam cedências e
pesadas não importa o barulho de fora
quando se lêem quando a gente consegue
se ouviu se o todo esse barulho se
transforma em silêncio e eu sei que o
caminho a gente encontrar nossa
consciência da gente a saltar aceitar
ele é um caminho bastante complexo dance
eu levei 18 20 anos para conseguir
encontrar mas eu acho que mais
importante do que esse agente sendo bem
e procurar transmitiu bem para o outro
eu me sinto um pouco pastor dizendo
essas coisas mas por eu virei uma pessoa
otimista porque eu acredito no ser
humano não é nosso potencial como ser
humano eu acho que o movimento deve vir
de dentro pra fora sempre
hoje se fala muito sobre o empoderamento
do outro quando a gente pode empoderar
outras pessoas mas eu acho que a gente
não pode empoderar ninguém o máximo que
a gente pode fazer é mostrar para as
pessoas que a gente está ao lado delas
nessa caminhada para o empoderamento vem
de dentro para fora e para as pessoas
que hoje ainda sofrem algum tipo de
preconceito que se sentem menos que os
outros por isso que acham que não são
merecedores de felicidade como já
aconteceu comigo e acabam caindo no
vício das drogas e do álcool de
endividamento e uma série de outros
vícios que eu tenho pra dizer pra vocês
é que a ansiedade de vocês dificuldade
de vocês só vão sair de dentro quando
vocês começarem a ouvir o que tem dentro
do coração de vocês vocês começaram a
compreender quem vocês ao mundo e como
vocês podem ser bacana para o mundo
eu acho que todos nós a gente pode muito
mais do que a gente imagina hoje a
partir do meu projeto da minha liberdade
conquistada eu consigo apoiar a causa
dos homossexuais como eu sem medo à
causa negra a causa das pessoas mais
velhas ea causa de qualquer ser humano
hoje eu acho que só a partir dos micro
revoluções que a gente consegue
transformar o mundo eu procuro fazer
isso todos os dias com diferentes gestos
na minha vida
hoje eu acho que nós somos todos iguais
e olha para aquela foto da minha
comunhão eu não me incomodo mais com
aquilo
eu acho bonito o jeito que estava
vestido eu tenho saudade dos meus
cabelos
obrigado eu acho que a nossa essência
ela fala muito de quem a gente é preciso
revisitar relação com a minha avó
a relação com a minha mãe a aceitação da
minha família da minha história para
poder reconstruir o ser humano eu sou
esse é um ser humano melhor com isso
e hoje eu desenvolvi gratidão por toda
essa caminhada porque se não tivesse
passado pela situação na comunhão pelas
situações de bullying que eu passei pela
violência que recebia eu não teria me
tornado ser humano que eu sou hoje por
isso eu acho importante a gente recebe
unificar as coisas negativas que
acontecem na vida o que eu digo pra
vocês e que hoje eu me sinto melhor ser
humano do mundo eu não acho que só eu
sou melhor ser humano do mundo acho que
todos nós todos nós somos melhores seres
humanos no mundo ea gente precisa
acreditar nisso porque o mundo já tem
bastante intolerância o brasil está
bastante polarizado enquanto a gente não
entender que só a partir do
empoderamento próprio a gente vai
conseguir transformar o mundo
a gente não vai sair desse status
eu acho que também é mais honesta gente
como a gente é do que ser como os outros
esperam que a gente seja e aqui eu cito
dois homossexuais que ao longo da
história pra mim foram bastante
significativos sofreram preconceito
também mas conseguiram fazer o bom disso
um deles foi o hard mil que nos estados
unidos que acabou sendo vítima de um
assassinado por defender causas
homossexuais na década de 60 e outro foi
incompreendido essa época que o caio
fernando abreu gaúcho acabou sendo
vítima da aids e que hoje tem seus
textos popularizadas aí na internet
e pra finalizar o meu recado que eu
queria dizer pra vocês é colocar essa
pergunta por qual motivo meu afeto que
afeta por qual motivo a gente é tão
intolerante
eu espero que foi a partir disso a gente
consiga desenvolver um pouco mais
empatia e fazer do mundo algo muito mais
significativo
obrigado